and let's
get you some breaking news out of sudan
because we are hearing that the army
chief there has appointed a new ruling
sovereign council you'll recall that
last month abdel fattah al-burhan
dissolved sudan's transitional
government and he also detained civilian
leaders in a military takeover let's uh
get more on this story hibber morgan is
joining us on the line from uh khartoum
what more do we know about this
announcement that's been made
well the announcement was made on state
television and the members that are
included in the sovereignty council have
been announced it includes china abdel
fattah al-burhan who is the head of the
sovereignty council the same position he
held in the previous sovereignty council
which he dissolved on the day of
takeover on october 25th his deputies
will be general muhammad mohammed hamdan
that's the head of the paramilitary
rapid support forces also included in
that sovereignty council are the members
the military members of the dissolved
sovereignty council so
some faces of that new sovereignty
council come from the old one that was
dissolved by the general on the day of
the military takeover they're also
members of the armed groups they also
retained their position as per juba
peace agreement signed between the
transitional government which was
dissolved and the various armed groups
in the south korean capital juba in
october 2015 and 2020. so uh some of
those members and some of those members
in the sovereignty council
that were read out today come from the
old sovereignty council but they're also
new members on the list some of them are
independent as per their positions which
they were um
they were running for or and rather
during political campaign uh they were
claiming they were independent and
others are new names that were not in
the previous government members the
billion members from the forces of
freedom and change coalition are not
included in the sovereignty council and
this all comes as people continue to
protest against the military takeover
we've seen mass protests on october 30th
against the military takeover saying
that they don't want the army to decide
the governing uh pillars of this
transitional government and they've
rejected the takeover and anything that
would come with it so this is likely to
inflame the protest movement further
there has been calls and mobilizations
for protests from war protests rather on
november 13th and if anything with
protesters angry at the takeover it is
likely that we will see this decision
angering them more okay and we will keep
an eye out on the streets heber morgan
for the time being thank you so much for
that update from cartoon